how do you sell advertising I got a
question from a facebook reader faith
who's trying to start up a new
publication and is looking for
advertisers and her challenge here is if
she doesn't get advertisers for her
business it's not going to take off
because even if she has great content a
great idea if everything is coming out
of her pocket it's not going to last
it's not going to work because her
pocket is not unlimited
so she needs advertisers to pay for this
thing to help it get off the ground and
she wanted my step-by-step advice on
what to do so faith great question
Congrats we wanted to set up this
business here are a few things for you
really important step-by-step advice to
help guide you along your way the first
thing you want to do to find an
advertiser is you start by making a list
so you think about every single company
that is already advertising to your
target market I always prefer to go with
companies who are who are already
advertising because they have a budget
if you're trying to go to new companies
we've never done any advertising before
it rarely works out because you have to
convince them to start advertising when
they've never done it before it's
possible but it's so much harder
compared to companies who are already
spending a lot of money in your space so
start by making a list of every company
who's advertising to your market now
faith is starting a publication for
homeschooling parents so who's her
target audience in terms of advertisers
anybody who's trying to sell the parents
and it's huge there's so many companies
who are trying to target parents
especially new parents especially young
parents who have you know their first
kids coming out so those are the
comforts of target to find that list
look at any trade shows that deal with
babies or young kids look at any
publications that are already out there
look at any websites that are out there
and just make a list of everybody who's
advertising in there the next thing is
step number two is you want to make a
list of the people who you can contact
at those businesses now this step is a
little bit harder so say for example
pampers is a company you want to target
you need to find somebody at pampers so
you can talk to about your campaign now
who you find really depends on
what your market is going to be so for
your own publication are you looking to
go just for your state just for your
city are you trying to go nationally
trying to go international the person
you connect with that the company will
really depend on what the scope of your
market is going to be so if you're just
trying to do a local regional campaign
something in your state then you need to
find somebody local if you're going for
a national campaign then you get bumped
up the scale a little bit my favorite
way to find people has actually been
through a website called jigsaw comm I'm
not affiliate them in any way other than
being a customer but it's a great way to
find people who work at a specific
company and have a specific job title so
you could go to the website type in
pampers to type in Johnson Johnson type
in marketing or type in advertising and
it'll generate a list of people who work
at that company and if you want to get
their email address you want to get
their phone number then you have to pay
$1 to do it but it's a highly targeted
list and so you can go to the website
and start finding the people who you
need to connect with and you can see
what their title is you don't want to
shoot too high if you're just trying to
do something in your city you don't want
the national advertising manager as you
start to build your list then you get a
targeted group of people who you can
actually connect with and then the next
step is to start reaching out to them
and if it's by email or by phone or by
person you need to start reaching out
and don't hesitate if they start
rejecting you or if they don't respond
to you and that's going to happen
especially at the beginning so the key
elements in making them say yes is
looking at your pitch and if you're
going to break down your pitch I'd say
there are three key things that you need
to remember the first is sustained for
something what is it that makes your
publication so much different better
unique compared to everything else
that's out there because if you're the
same thing as everything else there's no
reason to go with you remember these
advertisers are getting pitched on an
ongoing basis by publications by all
sorts of different outlets trying to get
their money so you need to be different
you need to be unique you need to stand
out and you do that
by standing for something so what do you
stand for are you trying to get more
people to become homeschooling parents
are you trying to make the lives of
homeschooling parents easier what is it
like why are you starting this thing
that's going to come across in your
message if they believe in the same
thing as you do it's going to be so much
easier to convince them to give you
their advertising others that's the
first thing the second thing is show
some momentum a lot of times the people
who are pitching these advertisers have
zero - no momentum they don't have
anything going yet it's really hard to
give dollars to a startup that's never
proven themselves right why am I going
to spend ten thousand dollars five
thousand dollars a thousand dollars
whatever it is with you if you've never
done anything before so show some
momentum wherever you are at in your
progress show that you've done something
show some examples of the stories are
going to write show some examples of the
feedback that's already coming back do
something online create a campaign if
it's on Facebook something to show that
you have a readership base that people
need this thing obviously if you've
already published a few it's easier to
show that but if you haven't done that
yet again show as much momentum as you
can instead of you're saying hey I have
an idea and I'm looking for an
advertiser because you're not going to
get through you've got to show that
you're more than just an idea and then
three find a way to help get them
started at really low cost low
investment and then over deliver like
crazy this one is so important starting
off a new relationship with any company
is always risky it's a risk not just in
terms of their money but also in terms
of their time right they're spending
time with you they're not spending time
with somebody else and they don't want
to make the wrong decision they don't
want to invest their money in the wrong
company and spend their time on projects
that aren't going to work out so because
of that risk they're probably going to
say no and so the way to get them to say
yes is to reduce that risk make it super
easy to get them involved either free or
really minimal commitment at the start
and then over deliver like crazy show
them some results
and as you do that you're going to be
able to increase your prices on
go off and get new advertisers as well
so as an example from my background I I
was hired a number of times to write
blog posts for companies and the first
blog post I wrote they asked me for 250
words 300 words something like that and
instead of just doing that instead of
just doing the bare minimum I wrote like
2,000 words 1,500 words I included a
video I promoted to my audience I got
way more results in what they were
expecting they just wanted me to write
an article and instead I wrote a way
longer article added video content
promoted to my audience
drove tons of traffic to their website
and over delivered like crazy as a
result they hired me back again and
again and again and I increased my
prices that first blog post they paid me
$500 to do now to write a blog post is
$2,500 it's the same content the same
process that I go through but I'm
offering way more value and I can prove
it to them and now when companies ask me
how much is it and I say $2,500 and they
say $2,500 to write one blog post I can
show them what I've done there's a track
record there's a history and so you need
to build that up and so if you go in
right away asking for top dollar they're
probably going to say no so find ways to
reduce that risk at the start so you can
show that you're going to be able to
deliver solid results for them hopefully
that helps if you want send me your
pitch send me what you're sending out
and I'll do a review for you and let you
know what I think of it and where you
can improve because this is so important
it's so important because a lot of
entrepreneurs have these great ideas
have noble ambitions and and doing it
not just for yourself but doing it to
better your community right if this is a
resource that is really lacking in the
homeschooling community then this needs
to get done you need to find a way to
make this happen if you're doing this
just to make money then then I'm not
interested in helping you but if there's
a reason behind that something powerful
something where you want to give back
and have an impact on people then people
can wrap
léa around that and it's so important
that you get this thing done and I don't
want something as simple as finding
advertisers to hold you back from
achieving your dream just because it's
not an area of expertise that you're
really good at with work with effort
with passion you can overcome that
challenge and build a hugely successful
company believe for those of you
watching you liked the video please give
it a thumbs up below and always want to
do more for you and hey I want to hear
we have to think please leave a comment
underneath let me know what you think if
you have a question for your business
leave it below I'll do a video response
thank you guys I'll see you soon